et ben voilà avec cette blouse rapiécé
et ceux du chapeau moi je trouve que mon
épouvantail à une bien fière allure et
avec un peu de vent pour le faire bouger
les petits oiseaux penseront que c'est
un être humain bien vivant comme ça
quand on sera pas là mais ils n'auront
pas le toupet de venir chiper des
bonbons monsieur l'épouvantail vous êtes
très élégant vous allez être très
agréable habitants de l'île
cher monsieur l'épouvantail ça alors il
y à un nouvel habitant dans l'île aux
enfants
c'est incroyable il est vraiment très
élégant ce monsieur il est encore plus
distingué comme monsieur du snob et moi
qui ne me suis pas habillé et et moi
monsieur l'épouvantail de vous présenter
notre ami casimiro bonjour monsieur les
puces ma taille je suis enchanté mais
qu'il ne veut pas me donner la main en
soit 10 mois
il habille puce l'épouvantail casimir
pas les plus lentes à yalaoui opus est
l'époux les puces c'est la même famille
faut pas tirer une drôle de tête
il a vraiment une drôle de tête mais dis
moi c'est une nouvelle race ou bien
alors il l'a il a des origines
préhistoriques comme les casimir us à
l'union casimir garde il est fait avec
du bois de la paille et des vieux habits
ya dix minutes il n'existait pas encore
mais alors il n'est pas en rivaux
ben non c'est un mannequin et je les ai
fabriqués pour faire peur aux oiseaux
ça alors mais pourquoi voulez vous faire
peur aux oiseaux ils voulaient tous mes
bonbons au miel
comment savez vous que c'est que ce sont
les oiseaux qui volaient les bonbons
d'autant que gémir
qui d'autre veux tu que ce soit je ne
sais pas moi en tout cas ce n'est pas
moi
nous n'avions pas pensé à casimir c'est
peut-être lui ah bah non non non je ne
crois pas parce que normalement il
n'aime que les dragées au poivre et tu
n'en as pas françois oui les jolies vous
mode et sauver beaucoup ce n'est pas
gentil du tout de faire peur aux oiseaux
que vont penser les enfants mais nous ne
faisons pas de mal mais non et chez
casimir comme ils sont très malins les
petits oiseaux
après s'être envolé de peur une première
fois ils verront bien que l'épouvantail
n'est pas méchant et ils viendront même
se percher dessus bon alors pourquoi
avez-vous un rhdp tout ça ça ne sert à
rien la regarder ça de plus près aux
dégraderont j'adore ça c'est délicieux
du sein avec de la moutarde et de la
confiture de fraises c'était un joueur
n'est pas pour toi
or j'ai compris c'est pour mes amis les
oiseaux exactement casimir et je vais
t'expliquer notre plan avec
l'épouvantail nous faisons peur aux
oiseaux qui n'osent plus s'approcher du
kiosque alors il s'envole un peu plus
loin et là ils découvrent les graines
que leur a préparé julie ainsi qu'en
l'épouvantail leur fera plus peur mais
ils ont pris l'habitude de manger des
graines y laisseront les bonbons au miel
de julie poinot françois il y a des
moments où tu m'étonnes tu sais que ton
idée n'est pas bête du tout merci pour
les autres fois parce que tu penses que
c'est toi quel toujours les meilleures
idées que moi et alors
védie voulait dernière eh bien je viens
d'inventer une nouvelle collection
vraiment vraiment en quoi
consiste-t-elle pour écouter a insisté
encore un peu et puis je vous le dirai
peut-être nous assistons des émirats les
10 nuls eu vite et bien voilà j'ai
regroupé des objets qui représentent
chacun un des habitants de l'île à essai
destiné je pense aux visiteurs qui
viennent se promener dans l'îlot
z'enfants exactement c'est en quelque
sorte un musée amusé vingt mille francs
soir c'est quoi exactement un musée dans
mon vieux kazimierz et
tellement ce que tu es en train de faire
un musée c'est une collection d'objets
qui sortait illustrés chacun l'histoire
de quelqu'un ou de quelque chose c'est
vrai mais je suis formidable j'ai
inventé un musée sans savoir ce que
c'était qu'un musée alors montré les bus
est visé écoutez un boni voir alors
voila mon musée ouais mais qu'est ce qui
se passe mais il ne me reste plus
plombant le gloubiboulga pourtant je
vous assure il y avait une quantité
d'objets très intéressant c'est un peu
maigre pour faire un musée qu'est ce
qu'il y avait d'autres parce qu'il y
avait par exemple pour la can et le
chapeau de monsieur du snrtc la sacoche
et la casquette du facteur il y avait
des plus beaux ballons il y avait les
bonbons au miel
julie il a laissé accusés déjà mis les
petits oiseaux
ouais mais alors on écoute casimir le
cedus noble facteurs ont dû reprendre
leurs effets et les enfants ont pris des
balles ou et les bonbons bas c'est
normal c'est pour eux écoutez venir tu
n'as qu'à recommencer sa collection mais
cette fois on demandera chacun ne te
confier un objet d'accord d'accord
l'accord bon et bien une main à tout à
l'heure je vais chercher de nouveaux
jouets à l'arrivée du bateau je
t'accompagne julie jetant contact des 2
états unis ouais bon courage pour ton
musée merci au revoir au travail
bon il faut que je retrouve tous les
objets que j'avais là mais cette fois il
faut que je trouve un moyen pour qu'on
ne les reprenne pas je crois que j'ai
une idée
voilà bien ainsi déguisés en orangs
l'épouvantail personne n'ose s'approcher
trop près et de reprendre les objets de
mon musée j'entends quelqu'un qui vient
manger rémy c'est insensé
ça fait deux fois que ma qu'elle
disparaisse incroyable
ne vous plaignez pas trop monsieur du
snob votre canne ne vous ai guère
indispensable pas vrai je regrette mon
cher et blessant de laquelle je ne suis
plus tout à fait le même
je me sens comme un verre et en société
croyez moi c'est terriblement gênante
mais pour moi moi c'est bien pire
on m'a dérobé ma sacoche et ma casquette
comment voulez vous que je travaille
dans ces conditions on vous pouvez
mettre vos lettres dans votre poche vous
n'avez jamais des kilos à distribuer ça
c'est vrai poursuivre ici c'est la bonne
place ma casquette ne vous reste plus
qu'à mettre notre motion sur la tête et
vous protégera du soleil oui mais les
signes des facteurs tirent sur la
casquette rapport sur pour sûr j'en suis
je suis désolé aux moines mais venez
voir monsieur du snob
ce sont nos affaires au mais vous avez
raison allons les récupérer mon ami oh
mais quel est cet individu mais je lis
nous ont mis ma mère très menaçants
rebrousse
en chemin rancinan cependant qu'il est
encore tôt suivez moi et nous a
peut-être en passe encore plus quand on
va chez mes amis attention attention il
ya du danger là bas quelques engins non
l'île aux enfants
il ya là bas un individu que je
n'aimerais pas rencontré la nuit au coin
d'un bois
ce que tu pourrais peut-être à le voir
ses crédits de plus près oui il a pas
l'air bien méchant écoutez je rien dans
ces stocks ne bougeait paraissait
quasiment les émirs en épouvantail
eh ben on aura tout vu c'est rien c'est
casimir qui s'est déguisé en épouvantail
en plus des 100 demandes d'emploi 1
pourquoi donc eh bien je crois qu'il
veut vous faire peur afin que vous leur
panier pas les objets qu'ils à
rassembler c'est ça il faut vous dire
que casimir a constitué un musée mais
laury d'une le tire enfin à canoniser
c'est très flatteur tu veux je veux je
m'étonne
non le papillon on va aller le féliciter
et le remercier
bonjour monsieur l'épouvantail pas kaka
nous venons visiter le musée de casimir
l'approché pas prêt vous pouvez regarder
mais ne rien toucher
ne vous inquiétez pas on ne touchera
rien mais où est-il kazemi
nous voudrions le remercier pour sa
bonne idée ah bon alors attendez je vais
aller le chercher
oui vous avez fait connaissance avec mon
ami l'épouvantail je crois pas c'est le
meilleur gardien que j'ai jamais vu il
faut dire que grâce à lui nous n'avons
touché aucun objet il a une autorité
formidable et je dois dire que je les
trouvais une certaine élégance
ah bon et bien commençons la visite du
musée suivez le guide
voilà tout d'abord vous pouvez voir le
chapeau et la canne du très célèbre
monsieur du snob à un peu plus loin
splendide balou un des plus beaux
spécimens de la collection privée de
françois c'est mon préféré c'est l'homme
ensuite la magnifique casquette de
monsieur campagne facteur de lilas et sa
sacoche
ensuite dans le bocal les caramels mous
grande spécialité de julie en bas du
bord les véhicules autorisés sur l'île
aux enfants et tout au bout le fameux le
célèbre bol qui sert